mais si michel field
ou alors retour d'un michel qu'il
bonsoir pour sur terry vous revenez avec
un livre qui s'appelle le livre des
rencontres michel fils que vous avez
écrit avec julie cléo et qui est publié
chez robert laffont vous savez comment
on fait j'ai vu un truc mal élevé mais
je vais pas fait j'ai pas osé le faire
fait le vas-y mais non alors c'est un
recueil d'histoires de rencontres
amoureuses vécue par des anonymes ou des
célébrités
alors vous raconter des histoires
extraordinaires l'histoire de charlotte
et eric il se rend compte trois fois de
suite c'est incroyable hasard c'est
presque le sait le prototype de la
question est ce que c'est un du hasard
ou est-ce que c'est écrit par dieu le
destin et tout s'est tu
c'est un couple ils se rencontrent la
première fois dans le tgv ils reviennent
des sports d'hiver lui il est avec des
gens elle l est avec une copine voilà et
puis ils partagent le même compartiment
dans le tgv ils discutent un petit peu
et ils se quittent sur le quai de la
gare de lyon sans se donner leur adresse
ni leur téléphone trois jours après elle
sort du boulot elle prend le bus ce
qu'elle ne fait jamais et dans le bus
le mec monte il repart l'ensemble est le
mec a juste le temps de lui dire ah ben
oui je prends le bus parce que j'ai pas
de voiture à paris j'en ai une à prague
donc elle sort du bus elle c'est que le
mec s'appelle eric et qui travaille à
prague c'est tout et elle va un dîner
chez des copains et elle l'a elle se
rend compte que vraiment c'est deux fois
c'est beaucoup et elle dit à ses copains
écouter voilà faut m'aider à retrouver
ce mec je suis tombé sur un type
s'appelle eric il travaille à prague
c'est tout ce que je sais lui faut
m'aider à le retrouver
et c'est là où vraiment l'histoire est
extraordinaire dans ce dîner il ya une
ac mais attends moi j'ai un copain qui
va ouvrir dans trois semaines un
restaurant à prague
on va te faire inviter à l'inauguration
parce que la communauté française de
prague
elle est pas l est pas et n'a donc il
part sur celle partie sur cette idée là
et puis deux jours après la rappelle sa
copine je peux pas attendre trois
semaines fait moi rencontrer ton copain
entre temps la cabine a appris que le
type en question à un associé qui
s'appelle eric elle
dîner en disant il ya une chance sur dix
mille que cet eric soit le bon l'ananas
et ils sont ensemble ils ont fait nos
enfants jamais personne qu'ils appuient
poté aussi parce que turin ita non une
vraie histoire va lancer on est en boîte
on est tous les deux bourgs et non
mariés qui partent de cherrie non mais
c'est vrai que l'histoire d'eric et
charlotte pour un esprit rationalise
c'est troublant quand on finit par
croire la destinée est justement utilise
un truc très très joli disque quand ils
s'engueulent
comme tous les coups parce qu'ils ont
fait des gosses et là il ya eu à l'usure
de au moment où ils se demandent s'ils
vont passer par il ya un an enfin notre
rencontre a été trop marquée par la
reddition l'insistance du destin on peut
pas gâcher ça alors il ya des anonymes
donc comme charlotte eric et aussi des
stars il ya jacques weber par exemple
qu'ils rencontrent pas raconter
l'histoire c'est extraordinaire alors il
rencontre christine sas qui est devenue
sa femme du président la seconde en
boîte dans une boîte à bénodet à la ils
arrivent ils vous à cette fille au
comptoir dont c'était une époque il le
dit lui même louis de radier volontiers
avec un copain et il prend son copain
par le brel il regarde cette femme c'est
la femme de ma vie est là il m'assure
que c'est quelque chose qu'il n'avait
jamais dit il va avoir cette jeune femme
et il arrive comme ça il était déjà si
tu pas encore le il était bon aussi
connu qu'il l'ait maintenant ils
n'étaient déjà un peu il arrive à port
ou landais mécanique
ouais je suis acteur et ou la nana rien
elle ne connaît rien de lui écrit cindy
assez drôlement que la première séance
de drague a été triste comme la notice
d'un dictionnaire des acteurs parce que
jacques vue a raconté comme il a en plus
boulimique de travail toutes les pièces
qu'il avait montré toutes les pièces
dans lesquelles il avait joué et puis il
y avait quelque chose qui l'irrité dans
le fait que c'est sa passion le théâtre
et il est en vacances avec jean françois
balmer chaque il souffre de son projet à
bâle n'est requis midi mais attends tu
es foutu la tribune qu lisez tout est en
fête toute la nuit il fait des affiches
à la main une plaque hassan chez les
commerçants de bénodet il va voir le mec
qui tient la boîte il dit
ta boîte elle ouvre à minuit je te
lahlou de 9h à minuit et il circule dans
bénodet hangeland sa voiture avec un
mégaphone
ce soir représentations exceptionnelles
jacques weber et le spectacle qui tourne
depuis 20 ans qui s'appelle seul en
scène il est né d'un montage de textes
qui l'a fait uniquement pour que cette
jeune femme sache qui était jacques
weber sur scène c'est quand même une
centenaire
alors j'en ai retenu nos que c'est
l'histoire de xavier couture dont qui
désormais dirige canal+ et de claire
chazal et donc moi c'est xavier coup dur
qui me l'a racontée sur pas laurent
baffie qui lui il flashe sur clerc à
deux reprises une fois où il l'a croisé
dans les bureaux de feu la cinq où elle
venait comme ça rendez vous donc il a
regarni et tout affaibli elle ne le voit
évidemment pas et une deuxième fois un
vrai coup de foudre mais pareil très
très métaphysique quoi puisque elle est
en train de présenter le 20h sur une
plage de normandie pour la célébration
du débarquement américain
et là il la voit sur la plage avec les
les projecteurs de la télé en train peu
en train d'officialiser une prêtresse de
l'information et lui il y à côtés
d'étienne mougeotte est vraiment il
tombe raide amoureux d'elle mais il ne
va pas lui dire tout de suite
surtout qu'à l'époque claire n'est pas
seul et puis clerc se sépare de son
compagnon du moment et il va se
retrouver dans la situation assez
compliquée de d'être chargés par
l'ancien copain de claire d'essayer de
les accommoder at il dit il dit je le
crois puisque c'est un ami qu'il s'est
acquitté de sa tâche avec énormément de
loyauté rivaux du feydeau voilà il s'est
alors lui il j'ai été loyal à dire j'ai
été le porteur du message de
réconciliation mais j'ai dû en faire des
tonnes pour que ça foire et en effet ça
a foiré ils se sont mariés voilà voilà
et puis il ya votre histoire que vous
pouvez raconter thierry dalem j'ai
raconté dans le bouquin
donc c'est vrai que j'arrive je t'avais
qu'une fille à l'époque je vais divorcer
de trois ans avant de ma première femme
est jetée avec une fine twitteuse avec
qui on rigolait bien et un jour j'arrive
dans une boîte et je vois c'était aux
privilèges au sous-sol du palace et je
vois une fille une petite brune comme ça
assise sur une chaise avec un sac sur
les innovations vachement sage comme ça
et je lui dis on va se marier la fidic
c'est ce vieux cochon qui vient me
donner beaucoup plus jeune loup est bien
sûr il reste quinze ans qu'est ce que
c'est ce vieux cochon qui vient de
dragage écoute et vous verrez et à ce
moment là fille avec qui j'étais
renverse comme par hasard un tequila
sunrise sur la fille pour bien montrer
que ce qu'elle en pensait et puis elle
disparaît et moi je me renseigne on me
dit elle est en angleterre et comme j
des alizés beaucoup j'imagine qu'il est
dans un couvent bras
elle ne présente que dans un couvent et
donc j'attends bien jour mondiale est
revenue quand donc on se revoit je me
suis à la coupole
j'en fumais plein de cigarettes mais
c'est très tendu tous les deux comme ça
au bar la coupole et effectivement elle
me dit me produis tout je m'occupais
d'une galerie de peinture à londres vous
auriez pu venir me voir et c'est déjà et
puis on discute je vais apporter un
livre aussi comme jacques weber pour
montrer que j'étais quand même quelqu'un
de bien je la porte un peu un call
oublie évidemment et y ce samedi que
c'est normalement j'ai couru derrière
avec le chic pour le relever et elle m'a
fait attendre pendant trois mois
faut faire attendre au bout de trois
mois je lui dis quand même c'est un peu
bernadette soubirous vaut quand même
hélas elle a complètement vexé c'était
génial elle est tombée le pen et ça fait
vingt ans que ça dure et on a trois
enfants
alors il a une histoire qui n'est pas
dans le livre c'est la vente mon cher
ami avec julie que les eaux alors
raconté cette histoire c'est
extraordinaire parce que vous vous la
connaissez vous bossez avec elle on
travaille une saison ensemble bon et
puis c'est vrai que je suis plutôt à
séparer le boulot de la vie hippie
néanmoins sur la fin de la saison on se
rend compte qu'il ya un début
d'ambiguïté dans nos relations mais
julie allait se marier quelques semaines
plus tard donc on s'avoue à peine enfin
vraiment c'est resté très comme ça mezza
voce qu'il y avait une petite ambiguïté
et puis de toute façon le mariage était
la mécanique du mariage est lancée elle
était avec le son futur mari depuis
plusieurs années il vivait ensemble donc
les choses étaient trop balbutiante pour
que l'on fasse une sorte d' alerte d'
alerte rouge quoi donc le mariage a eu
lieu moi j ai été invités puisque
j'étais son boss donc au départ j'ai
j'ai trouvé que c'était mieux de pas y
aller et puis après je suis ça lui
ferait peut-être de la peine
donc je croyais en lui faire plaisir je
suis allé à son mariage ce qui en fait
la salle a totalement pulvérisées elle
n'avait aucune envie de choix là et donc
elle s'est mariée et elle a divorcé
quasiment dans la foulée quoi parce que
quand on a recommencé à travailler
ensemble en septembre on avait un petit
peu naïvement pensé que ce mariage
allait calmer nos débuts d'ardeur ça n'a
fait que les redoublé et voilà et elle a
vécu elle un enfer à servas parce que ça
se passait dans les milieux de la bonne
bourgeoisie du manoir magistrature
bamboo enfin bref
et alors là on lui a fait un procès en
sorcellerie comme imaginer beaucoup
d'amis
voilà tous ces animaux du genre
caricatural tenir les gens qui la
croisent sur le trottoir manger up et il
chante pour toi et pas lui dire bonjour
après une sorte de chat de sorcière
enfin ce qu'on lit dans la littérature
du 19e siècle
c'est à cause de vous michel quand même
l'avouer mais rêve de culpabiliser un
petit peu non j'ai jamais culpabilisé
parce que je dis toujours dit à julie
devant ces réactions lâché 10 coups de
même si notre histoire dure pas le seul
fait que jeter arraché à ce milieu de
connard mérite de deux façons pour les
vécus et de toute façon ce sera bien
pour toi et puis voilà on est ensemble
on a une petite manon il ya deux ans et
demi et on et voilà et tous ces gens là
globalement on les emmerde et moi en
tout cas
et en plus ce qui ne gâche rien c'est
que cette unité est très jolie pareil
pareil pour le voir tout de suite elle
est là catherine faire se bat
melvin fait la rentrée
à trévoux alors est ce que vous
confirmez
julie tout ce qui vient d'être racontée
par michel j'avais perdu tous vos amis
oui ce que les amis mais en fait c'est
un peu difficile au début forcément
parce que on perd tout mais finalement
ceux qui sont restés seulement et ils
sont toujours là mais vous êtes pas dit
à un moment bon j'ai j'ai brisé vraiment
mon mariage j'ai perdu tous mes amis je
j'étais victime effectivement un procès
en sorcellerie et peut-être qu'avec
field ça va pas durer ça a duré 6 mois
vous n'êtes pas dire non je suis moi
c'est déjà une heure j'ai fait une
énorme connerie
non parce que c'était la première fois
que j'étais avec quelqu'un qui était
attentionné qui me disait que j'étais
jolie qui m'aimait comme ça qui me fait
pas qui m'apprenez plein de choses et
donc non je me disais que cette façon ce
qui est pris n'est que je suis belle et
ému et fier comme un pape étaient tous
là presstalis à talons de votre bouquin
le livre des ruptures après alors on
avance et ça marchait bord du candidat à
bernard barrault et désigne al et qui
sont mes éditeurs depuis 18 ans jeridi
ont fait ni des rencontres et si ça
marche avec les mêmes dans deux ans
bravo